ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
WELL. GORGEOUS BRADFORD
CABALLERO CHIANG DALLY DODD.
THE RUSSELL GALGIANI GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROWTH HERTZBERG HELLO.
HUESO TADO JACKSON JONES LEYVA
MCGUIRE MITCHELL MINING WARLOCK
MORALE NIELSEN CAN CERTAIN TINO.
ROTH RUBIO SKINNER STERN.
NUMBER BY CASKEY WIENER WILK.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WITH THE MEMBERS IN OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED
THIS MORNING IN PRAYER- BY OUR
CHAPLAIN SYSTEM CHAU GORMAN
AFTER WHICH WILL ASK YOU TO
REMAIN STANDING IN WOULD BE LET
HIM PLEDGE THIS MORNING BY
SENATOR TALLY. LET US REMEMBER
THIS RARE GOT IN GOD'S HOLY
PRESENCE. GREAT BUT AS WE
REMEMBER THE WITNESS OF
UNCONDITIONAL LOVE LIVED BY
REVEREND DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR. WE ASK YOU THIS
DAY. HELP US SICK COWS AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THE REASONS FOR OUR
SLOW PROGRESS IN DISMANTLING
RACISM. HELP US TO FACE OUR
FEARS RESISTANCE PRIDE AND
SHAME WHATEVER CONSCIOUS OR
UNCONSCIOUS MOTIVES HOLD US
BACK FROM VALUING AN ANTI
RACIST MULTI CULTURAL SOCIETY.
GOD OUR CIVIC AND RELIGIOUS
DECISIONS TO UPHOLD AND PROMOTE
THE RIGHTS OF ALL PERSONS
ESPECIALLY THOSE EXPERIENCING
MARGINALIZATION INJUSTICE
BIGOTRY AND PREJUDICE. CONTINUE
TO REMIND US THAT DIVERSITY IS
THE HALLMARK OF YOUR CREATION
THE MANIFESTATION OF YOUR
PRESENCE IN MERION SPARKS OF
YOUR DIVINE LIFE ON EARTH. WE
ASK THIS IN YOUR NAME AMEN.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN OUR
SALUTE TO OUR FLAGS I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG YEAH WE
ARE ALSO ALL OF WHICH IS WITH
FULL ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE. THE WRONG. OUR
MEMBERS. PRODUCE ON PRIVILEGES
OF THE FLOOR THERE ARE NINE.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ. MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. MOTION PRESSES. BROUGH
OF THE DAILY JOURNAL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE SENATE JOURNALS
FOR JANUARY THIRTEENTH THROUGH
THE SEVENTEENTH TWO THOUSAND
AND TWENTY WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
INTRODUCTION TO BILLS FROM
FIRST READINGS BILLS ARE DEEMED
READ. CONSIDERING
. MEMBERS WERE
TAKING UP CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I'M
HERE TODAY EXCUSE ME MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ- I'M SURE
SENATE RESOLUTION SIXTY SEVEN
BY SNATOR BRADFORD AND
RELATIVE TO DOCTOR MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR DAY. NOW
SENATOR REDFORD BUT BETTER
PRESIDENT I'M HERE TO PRESENT
SENATE RESOLUTION SIXTY SEVEN
HONORING AT THE MARTIN LUTHER
KING AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I
STAND HERE TODAY. HONOR TO
REPRESENT THE CAUCUS ALONG WITH
MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR HOLLY
MEANT TO THE RECOGNIZE THE
BIRTHDAY OF A GREAT AMERICAN
AND THEN IF HE'D BEEN ALIVE
TODAY WOULD BE. THE ONE HE
WOULD CELEBRATE FIRST BIRTH
IT'S PAST. WORK CHANGE. BILL
THAT WOULD HE WAS TAKEN FROM US
FAR TOO SOON. INDIVIDUAL WHO
ACCOMPLISH MANY FIRST A MORE SO
THAN MANY OF US ALL COMBINED HE
HAD ACCOMPLISHED BY THE YOUNG
AGE OF THIRTY NINE HE GRADUATED
HIGH SCHOOL BY FIFTEEN.
REQUIRED A COLLEGE DEGREE BY
THE AGE OF NINETEEN AND A PHD
BY THE AGE OF TWENTY SIX. I'M
HUMBLED TO RECOGNIZE AGAIN HIS
DEDICATED LIFE TO NONVIOLENCE
AND THE STRUGGLE FOR RACIAL AND
ECONOMIC EQUALITY IN THE UNITED
STATES AND ABROAD. A MAN WHO
OFTEN STATED IF YOU HAVEN'T
FOUND ANYTHING WORTHY TO ADOPT
A FOR YOUR GOOD FOR LEVIN. WELL
A GREAT MAN WHO WERE.
COURAGEOUS. UNTIL DOWN IS WHAT
HE DID. ACT NOW FOR OVER IN THE
FACE OF RELENTING VIOLENCE
HARASSMENT. HI AND THREATS OF
ADD TO LIVE SO FUTURE
GENERATIONS WOULD BE SAFE I
INDIVIDUAL WHO LIVE UNDER THE
LAST FIVE YEARS UNDER F. B. I.
C. I. A. AND CONSTANT POLICE
SURVEILLANCE I INDIVIDUAL WHEN
THE AUTOPSY WAS DONE AND THE
DOCTOR SAID YOU HAD A HEART OF
A SICK HE HAD A HEART OF A
SIXTY YEAR OLD MAN. BASED ON
THE STRESS THAT HE LIVED UNDER
CONSTANTLY I'M DAVID YOUR FACE
MULTIPLE DEATH THREATS THE
BOMBING OF HIS HOUSE WITH HIS
WIFE AND CHILDREN THERE. THE
STABBING OF HIMSELF IN NEW YORK
I'LL AT A BOOK SIGNING. AND
ULTIMATE TO ASSASSINATION EN US
SELMA. DOCTOR KING WAS A MAN
WHO. STRIVED TO BRING US
TOGETHER AND MEMBERS I ASKED
THAT REGARDS OF OUR PARTY. WE
SHOULD BE STRIVING TO SERVE OUR
COMMUNITY IN THE SAME MANNER
AND DOCTOR KING SAID HE OFTEN
SAID. WHAT ARE YOU DOING FOR
OTHERS BECAUSE HIS LIFE WAS OF
SERVICE HE OFTEN STATED WE ALL
CAN BE GREAT BECAUSE WE ALL
CONSERVE OUR VERGE DOESN'T HAVE
TO MATCH OUR KNOWLEDGE WE DON'T
NEED A COLLEGE DEGREE. TO BE
GREAT YOU JUST HAVE TO HAVE A
HEART OF LOVE. AND THAT'S WE
HAVE. IN NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR.
DR KING RECEIVED THE NOBEL
PRIEST PEACE PRICE IN OSLO
NORWAY. FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
AGAIN OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT AND ITS STEADFAST
COMMITMENT TO ACHIEVING RACIAL
JUSTICE NEW NON VIOLENCE HE WAS
THIRTY FIVE YEARS OLD THE
YOUNGEST RECIPIENT OF THE NOBEL
PEACE PRIZE BUT GETTING THERE
REQUIRED A LOT OF TRIALS AND
TRIBULATIONS HE WAS ARRESTED
OVER TWENTY NINE TIMES. IN HIS
LIFE. MEMBERS ARE NOT WILLING
TO BE ARRESTED ONCE FOR
ANYTHING. AND HE RECEIVED A
MONETARY COMPENSATION FROM HIS
OF FOUR'S NOBEL PEACE PRIZE-
WHICH WOULD BE A C<c.cyan> INTO A</c>
BUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
A DAY HE DONATED IT ALL TO THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT DESPITE
NOT BEING A WEALTHY MAN AND
DESPITE THE OBJECTIONS OF
CORRETA SCOTT GETTING IT'S WIDE.
AT AT THIRTY FIVE LEGACY BECAME
THE YOUNGEST AMERICAN TO
RECEIVE THIS PRESTIGIOUS AWARD.
DR KING IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT HELP CHANGE PUBLIC
POLICY FROM SEGREGATION TO
INTEGRATION RESULTING IN A
REPEAL OF POST RECONSTRUCTION
ERA STATE LAWS SUCH AS JIM CROW
IN THE SOUTH. AND ENACTED HELP
IN ACT. NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT. THE NINETEEN
SIXTY FIVE VOTING RIGHTS ACT IN
OTHER ANTI DISCRIMINATION LAWS
AIMED AT IN INDIAN ECONOMICALLY
GOING SOCIAL SEGREGATION IN
AMERICA. AGAIN I'M FROM THE US
FAR TOO SOON. A DOCTOR KING WAS
ASSASSINATED FIFTY TWO YEARS
AGO- L. AS HE LET THE POOR
PEOPLE'S MARCH HE WAS THERE TO
ORGANIZE SANITATION WORKERS IN
SELMA WHO WERE. BEING
MISTREATED UNDERPAID AND EVEN
KILLED ON THE JOB. AND WE
SHOULD LOOK AT MONDAY AS NOT A
DAY OFF BUT A DAY ON A DAY OF
SERVICE AS DOCTOR KING WOULD
WANT US TO DO HE WOULD WANT TO
GO BACK INTO OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND ORGANIZE YOU WOULD WANT TO
GO BACK IN OUR COMMUNITY CAN
FIGHT AGAINST HOMELESSNESS HE
WOULD WANT US TO FIGHT AGAINST
POLICE BRUTALITY HE WOULD WANT
US TO FIGHT AGAINST ALL THAT
AND- THAT STILL EXISTS FIFTY
TWO YEARS. AFTER HIS DEATH. DR
KING OFTEN SAID OUR LIVES BEGIN
THE END THE DAY WE BECOME
SILENT. ABOUT THINGS THAT
MATTER THE MOST. IT'S SOME OF
THOSE ARE DYING HERE. HE OFTEN
SAID. AT THE END WE WERE ROOM
REMEMBER NOT. THE WORDS OF OUR
ENEMIES BUT THE SILENCE OF OUR
FRIENDS THERE TOO MANY OF US MY
FRIENDS THAT ARE SILENT ON THE
ISSUES THAT MATTER MOST TO DAY.
IN TWO THOUSAND TWO NOT ONLY IN
CALIFORNIA BUT IN THIS NATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
SENATOR HERTZBERG. THE
COMMENDED PRESIDENT. OUR UNITS
HE IS BORN. OF OUR COMMON
STRUGGLE FOR CENTURIES NOT ONLY
TO RID OURSELVES OF BONDAGE BUT
TO MAKE A PROFESSION OF ANY
PEOPLE. BY OTHERS AN
IMPOSSIBILITY. THESE INSPIRING
WORDS REFERENCE BUYERS STEAM
JEWISH CAUCUS CHAIR BEN ALLEN
ON THIS FLOOR LAST YEAR WERE
FIRST SPOKEN BY DOT DOCTOR
MARTIN LUTHER KIG IT IS
ADDRESSED TO THE NATIONAL
CONVENTION OF AMERICAN JEWISH
CONGRESS IN MAY NINETEEN FIFTY
EIGHT. HE WAS ONLY TWENTY NINE
YEARS OLD. DOCTOR KING'S WORDS.
AT THAT DAY TRANSCENDED THE
SUFFERING OF ANYONE PEOPLE AND-EVOKED A COMMON VISION FOR
CIVIL RIGHT SHARED BY THE
JEWISH AND AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES. THAT SACRED
KINSHIP. AND SHARED VISION IN
TOWARD THROUGHOUT THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT AS JEWS ACOSTA
THIS COUNTRY STOOD FIRMLY
ALONGSIDE DR KING AND OTHER
CIVIL RIGHTS LEADERS AND
ACTIVISTS DURING THE
MISSISSIPPI FREEDOM SUMMER IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR THE
SEGREGATION PROTESTS IN ST
AUGUSTINE FLORIDA THE SAME
YEAR. AND SOME OF IN NINETEEN
SIXTY FIVE DURING THAT HISTORIC
MARCH ACROSS THE EDMUND PETTUS
BRIDGE DR KING STOOD ARM IN ARM
WITH ONE OF THE MOST HOW
WARRING FIGURES IN THE JEWISH
MORAL IMAGINATION AT THAT TIME
RABBI ABRAHAM JOSH. JOSH WILL
HERSHEL. THE MARCH SHE SAID WAS
SO INSPIRING AND SO FOR FILLING
FOR HERSCHEL BUT LATER HE
CALLED WE CALL THAT HIS LEGS.
HE FELT WERE PRAYING. THREE
YEARS LATER TEN YEARS AFTER HIS
ADDRESS TO THE AMERICAN JEWISH
CONGRESS IN JUST TEN DAYS
BEFORE YOU WAS CUT DOWN BY THE
SAUCES BULLET DOCTOR KING MADE
ONE OF HIS LAST PUBLIC
APPEARANCES AT THE SIXTY EIGHTH
ANNUAL CONVENTION. OF THE
RABBINICAL ASSEMBLY. IT WAS
AGAIN INTRODUCED BY HIS DEAR
FRIEND AND BROTHER IN ARMS
RABBI HERSCHEL. MARTIN LUTHER
KING IS A SIGN THAT GOD HAS NOT
FORSAKEN THE UNITED STATES THE
IS A VOICE THE VISION AWAY. THE
WHOLE FUTURE OF AMERICA WILL
DEPEND UPON THE IMPACT AND
INFLUENCE OF DR KING. HOW TRUE
THIS HAS BEEN FOR THE MOMENT OF
HIS ASSASSINATION AT THE
LORRAINE HOTEL IN MEMPHIS ON
APRIL FOURTH NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT. MARTIN KING JUNIOR
BELONG THE AGES. BUT HIS LEGACY
IS DREAM LIVES ON HIS LIFE AN
EXTRAORDINARY BRAVERY INSPIRES
ALL OF US TO CONTINUE THE WORK
FOR JUSTICE AND EQUALITY. IN
THIS CHAMBER. THE CENTER
BRADFORD IT DID MEMBERS LET'S
NOT FORGET THAT THIS WAS A MAN
WHO WAS ARRESTED AND PUT IN
JAIL TWENTY NINE TIMES WHEN YOU
HAVE A VOICE AND YOU HAVE AN
IDEA IT'S ONE THING TO TALK
ABOUT IT'S ANOTHER THING WHEN
SOMEBODY HITS YOU OVER THE HEAD
WITH A BILL. VERY DIFFERENT
JUST SOLD FOR TWO. HOME WITH
HIS WIFE AND CHILDREN WAS BOND
THINK ABOUT ANY OF US WHAT IT'S
LIKE FOR THOSE STRUGGLES WHAT
IT MEANS TO STAND TALL FOR WHAT
YOU BELIEVE IN. ONE THING AS I
SAY THE SPEECH IS A WHOLE
NOTHER THING EVERYTHING YOU
HAVE INCLUDING YOUR FAMILY IN
DEVOTION TO IT. WE HONOR HIM
NOT WHICH IS YOUR PASSING
RESOLUTIONS A CENTER BRADFORD
SAID BUT HOW WE CONDUCT
OURSELVES EVERY SINGLE DAY. THE
RESPECT AND COMPASSION WE
SHOWED OTHERS IN EVERY ASPECT
OF OUR LIVES AND THE COURAGE
AND HUMILITY WE BRING TO THE
TASK OF MAKING THE WORLD A
BETTER PLACE. IN HEBREW WE SAY
THE CONTROL LEVER HA. MAY HIS
MEMORY BE FOR A BLESSING. AND
MADE HIS MAY THE DREAM HE
SHARED AND FOUGHT TO REALIZE
REMIND US OF WHAT IS POSSIBLE
IN A WORLD IN A WORLD IN WHAT
IS STILL LEFT TO BE DONE AND
HIS SISTER GORMAN SAID HE WAS A
MAN OF UNCONDITIONAL LOVE. THAT
IS A CRITICAL POINT TO MAKE ON
BEHALF OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
ESTEEMED LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE ON SR SIXTY. UNDER
DRAWS OF. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LET THE IN THE
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS IS MY
PLEASURE TO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SR SIXTY SEVEN WHICH
COMMEMORATES THE LIFE THE
STRUGGLES AND THE LEGACY OF DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING. HIS LIFE
SERVES AS AN EXAMPLE OF HOW ONE
PERSON CAN HAVE AN IMPACT ALL
YOUR LIFE HE STOOD FOR THE
VALUE OF UNITY AND THE POWER OF
SOLIDARITY. HE INSPIRED ARE. I
LEADERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY NOT
ONLY IN THE JEWISH COMMUNITY
AND THE LATINO COMMUNITY HE
CONNECTED WITH CESA CHAVEZ IN
THE LOTUS WHERE THAW AND THE
FARMWORKERS MOVEMENT. TO MAKE
THE MOVEMENT FOR NON VIOLENCE
AND WRECKED ACTION THE
STRONGEST AND WILL PUT MOST
POWERFUL MOVEMENT IN OUR
COUNTRY NY THEY DID THAT IN THE
STRUGGLES FOR FARMWORKERS
RIGHTS. HE HELD COMMUNIST
CONVERSATIONS HE GAVE POWERFUL
SPEECHES ABOUT THE MANY ISSUES
RELEVANT IN OUR SOCIETY TODAY.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WOMEN'S
RIGHTS AND THE PRO PEACE THE
ANTI WAR MOVEMENT. WHICH WAS
PRETTY EYES. AB FIVE MANY OF
THE SAME AND JUST SO THE DOCTOR
KING FOUGHT FOR AND OR WHICH
HE PAID THE ULTIMATE PRICE.
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND LATINOS
COULD FACE RACISM IN EDUCATION
HAVE FEWER OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY AND WE
CONTINUE TO BE TARGETED FOR
INCARCERATION AND DETENTION AT
HIGHER RATES THAN OTHER
AMERICANS WE ARE DEMONIZING
JUDGED ON THE COLOR OF OUR SKIN
AND NOT IN THE CONTENT OF OUR
CHARACTER. WE SEE THIS ON THE
RHETORIC COMING FROM OUR
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION IN THE
POLICIES THAT THEY PROPOSE
INCLUDING THE TREATMENT OF
ASYLUM WORKERS AT THE BORDER
AND THE- SEPARATION A BABY IN
THEIR MOTHER'S. TODAY WITH. DON
KING AND HIS LET SEE LET
KNOWLEDGE THE MANY MANY
COMMUNITY LEADERS AN ACT SENATE
JEWEL'S WHO FOLLOW DR KING'S
VERY BEEN HIS SPIRIT AND HIS
DREAM. BLACK AS- BEING THE SEPT
WHETHER I'M PROUD IN SUPPORT OF
THIS TROUBLED RESOLUTION AND
TRY AND HARD TO DO MY PART TO
UNDER DR KING'S LEGACY BY
ADVOCATING FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE. AND FIGHTING FOR
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC PROSPERITY
FOR ALL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. DOCTOR PAN. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS I
TO- RISE AND- STRONG SUPPORT
OF- THIS RESOLUTION WANT THANK
MY GOOD FRIEND FROM GARDENIA
FOR BRING THIS FORD AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO-
RECOGNIZE- DOCTOR KING WHO NOT
ONLY. OF COURSE WAS A- HUGE
CHAMPION FOR CIVIL RIGHTS- FOR
THE- BLACK COMMITTEE BUT FOR
ALL OF US AND- IDEA HERE IN
SACRAMENTO ACTUALLY LAST YEAR
WE CELEBRATED- DOCTOR KING HAD
COME TO SACRAMENTO STATE SPEAK.
IT TOWARD- ACTUALLY WANT THIS
LAST SPEECHES HE GAVE IN HIS
LIFE- IN RED AND REMEMBERING
THAT OCCASION. WAIT IT OUT THAT.
WAS WE SEE IS DOCTOR KING SEEMS
TO HAVE. NOT BE ISOLATD TODAY
BY MOST- PEOPLE HERE IN OUR
COUNTRY THAT THAT TIME RIGHT
BEFORE HIS DEATH HE WAS NOT IN
FACT IT WAS- WHEN HE CAME TO
SACRAMENTO STATE- HERE TO MY
COMMUNITY- THIS- HE WAS NOT
SOMEONE WHO IS BEING LOOKED UP
BEHIND BECAUSE- HE HAD THE
COURAGE. TO ALWAYS FIGHT FOR
WHAT HE BELIEVED IN WHAT WAS
RIGHT FOR CIVIL JUSTICE AND
THAT'S NOT ALWAYS POPULAR. THAT
NOT IS ALWAYS SOMETHING THAT.
OUR PRAISE YOU FOR WE TALKED
ABOUT THE DOCKING BEING
ARRESTED MULTIPLE TIMES OF
COURSE THE HATE THAT HE IN
TOWARD- AND ALSO EVEN TO THE
DEGREE OF PHYSICAL ASSAULTS ON
HIM AND HIS FAMILY. IT TAKES
COURAGE AND I THINK IF ANYTHING
ELSE AS WE CELEBRATE DOCTOR
KING. IS THAT IT'S NOT A DAY
OFF IT'S A DAY- ON- ON MONDAY
WHEN WE CELEBRATE. THE HIS- HIS
DAY- BUT IT'S SOMETHING WE NEED
CELEBRATE EVERY DAY. AND
CELEBRATE COURAGE SHE HAD AND I
THINK THAT'S THE BEACON WHICH
WE SHOULD REALLY BE REMEMBERING
HIM BY HIS COURAGE AND TO
EMULATE THAT COURAGE IN
STANDING UP FOR WHAT'S RIGHT
AGAIN I ONE THING MY GOOD
FRIEND GARDENIA. OFFERINGS
RESOLUTION FOR THANK YOU.
CENTER MOORLACH. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. I WAS TWELVE
YEARS OLD WHEN THE
ASSASSINATION OF MARTIN LUTHER
KING. HEARD AND IT WAS VERY
IMPACTFUL EVENTS AND SO WHEN.
MY BROTHER WAS ABLE TO TAKE A
POSITION. IN THE VICINITY OF
MEMPHIS TENNESSEE ONE OF THE.
SITES I WANTED TO VISIT WAS THE
LORRAINE MOTEL. AND THE
NATIONAL CIVIL RIGHTS MUSEUM I
WOULD ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU TO
PUT IT ON YOUR BUCKET LIST IF
YOU HAVE NOT VISITED IT IS.
VERY INSPIRED BOB. THE MOTEL
RAIN THE OWNER WOULD BLOCK OFF
THE TWO ROOMS AND THAT'S WHERE
THE- TOUR OF THE MUSEUM
CONCLUDES IT'S VERY PROFOUND
VERY MOVING. BUT A. MARTIN
LUTHER KING GAVE A VERY
INTERESTING SPEECH THE DAY HE
THE DAY BEFORE HE WAS
ASSASSINATED IT WAS A- CALLED
THE- I BEEN TO THE MOUNTAINTOP
IT REFERRING TO MOSES IN. MOUNT
NEBO AND. I'VE SEEN THE
PROMISED LAND I MAY NOT GET
THERE WITH YOU- BUT- I'VE- I'M
NOT FEARING ANY MAN. SO HE WAS
A MAN WITHOUT FEAR WITH
DETERMINATION AND SPIRIT AND-
ARE AN INCREDIBLE EXAMPLE SO
THANK YOU MARTIN LUTHER KING
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
SENATOR WIENER. I THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE- AS
CHAIR OF THE LGBT Q. OF
LEGISLATIVE OUR CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF THE RESOLUTION I
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR- FOR
BRINGING AT- MARTIN LUTHER
KING- IS AN INSPIRATION FOR ALL
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENTS- HERE-
AND AROUND THE WORLD- AND IN SO
MANY WAYS ARE REDEFINES WHAT IT
MEANS TO FIGHT FOR THE CIVIL
RIGHTS OF A COMMUNITY I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE THAT- ONE OF- DR
KING'S AUG CLOSEST ADVISERS AND
ALLIES- BEAR RUSTIN- WAS A GAME
MAN WHO WAS HORRIBLY-
MISTREATED BY THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND- BY.
CONGRESS AS AN ATTACK ON DOT
THAT'S THE WAY THE PACKING DR
KING BECAUSE HEAVEN ORBID HE
ASSOCIATED- WITH THE GAME MAN
SO. THAT IT. OR ANY THING TO
NOTE ABOUT DOCTOR KING HE WAS
ABOUT IN SO MANY WAYS
INTERSECTION ALLERGY- IN AN ERA
WHEN THAT WASN'T ALWAYS. THE
CASE- WE ALSO NEED TO REMEMBER
THAT TODAY WITHIN OUR LGBT
COMMUNITY WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
HUGE- INEQUITIES- RATES OF HIV
INFECTIONS AMONG- A GAY BLACK
MAN- ARE VERY DISPROPORTIONATE-
TO THE REST OF THE COMMUNITY. A
BLACK WOMEN- ALSO
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED- BY
NEW HIV INFECTIONS AS WELL AS
LACK OF ACCESS TO CARE- WE KNOW
THAT OUR TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY
IS VERY MUCH PHYSICAL RISK
TERMS OF VIOLENCE ASSAULTS
MURDERS. BUT VERY
DISPROPORTIONATELY ITS BLACK.
TRANS WOMEN WHO ARE BEING
ATTACKED AND MURDERED SO TODAY
WE HAVE SO MUCH WORK TO DO WORK
THAT DOT KING. MOVE FORWARD- WE
NEED TO AS THE WAR AND- SENATOR
BRADFORD YOU MAKE INCLUDE.
THANKS AND I WANT TO THANK ALL
MY COLLEAGUES TO. WHAT THE
VOICE TO THIS MEASURE AND
ESPECIALLY TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
ORANGE COUNTY WHO I MISSPOKE
WHEN I SAID HE WAS IN SALMAN IS
CORRECT HE WAS IN MEMPHIS
LEADING GARBAGE WORKERS ON THE
DAY BEFORE. HE WAS ASSASSINATED
AND THE LORRAINE MOTEL IF YOU
HAVEN'T VISITED IS A GREAT-
HISTORICAL SPOT OF FOR ALL THE
WRONG REASONS BUT ONE THAT IS
WORTH VISITING NONE THE LESS.
AND IT'S SOMEWHAT IRONIC. MANY
TIMES WHEN WE TALK ABOUT DOCTOR
KING WE TALK ABOUT. ONE
PARTICULAR SPEECH I HAVE A
DREAM. BUT IF YOU'VE EVER
LISTENED TO THAT SPEECH IN ITS
ENTIRETY THAT WAS NOT TO SPEECH
HE WAS GIVEN. HE WAS GIVING
EACH ON THE URGENCY OF NOW ON A
NATION. THAT IT MADE A PROMISE
TO ALL PEOPLE BLOCK AS WELL AS
WHITE. THE PROMISE OF FREEDOM
AND THAT THIS NATION HAD. WROTE
THE NEGRO. AYE INSUFFICIENT
CHECK THAT IT FAILED TO LIVE UP
TO THE PROMISE OF THE
EMANCIPATION. PROCLAMATION AND
HE STATED PATIENTS OF HIS GREAT
WEALTH IS NOT BANKRUPT. BUT IT
IS WHEN IT COMES TO THE NEGRO.
AND IT IS A HUNDRED YEARS AFTER
THE END OF THE MANSON PATIENT
PROCLAMATION. OUR AIM
MONUMENTOS DECREED CAME TO BE A
GREAT BEACON OF LIGHT FOR
MILLIONS OF NEGRO SLAVES WHO
HAD BEEN SEARED BY THE FLAMES
OF WITHERING INJUSTICE IT CAME
AS A JOYOUS DAYBREAK TO THE END
OF AT NIGHT. OF THEIR CAN
CAPTIVITY. HUNDRED YEARS LATER
THE NEGRO STILL NOT FREE. ONE
HUNDRED YEARS LATER THE LIFE OF
THE NEGRO IS STILL SADLY
CRIPPLED BY THE MANACLES OF SEX
SEGREGATION AND THE CHAINS OF
DISCRIMINATION. ONE HUNDRED
YEARS LATER THE NEGRO LIVES ON
A LONELY ISLAND OF POVERTY IN
THE MIDST OF VAST OCEANS A
MATERIAL PROSPERITY ONE HUNDRED
YEARS LATER THE NEGRO IS STILL
LANGUISHING IN THE CORNERS OF
AMERICAN SOCIETY. AND FINDS
HIMSELF AN EXILE IN HIS WHOLE
PLAN. SO WE COME HERE TODAY TO
DRAMATIZE A SHAMEFUL CONDITIONS
OF AMERICA AND I COULD GO ON.
AND SPEAK TO THE FACT THAT
AGAIN. AND IN A SENSE WE'VE
COME TO THIS NATION TO CAP BACK
CASH A CHECK. WHEN THE
ARCHITECT OF THIS REPUBLIC
WROTE THE MAGNIFICENT WORDS OF
THE CONSTITUTION AND
DECLARATIONS OF INDEPENDENCE
THEY WERE SIGNING A PROMISSORY
NOTE. TO WHICH EVERY AMERICAN
FALLS HERE THIS NOTE WAS A
PROMISE TO ALL MEN YES BLACK
MEN AS WELL AS WHITE MEN THAT
WOULD BE GUARANTEED AN AILING
BUT WILL ALL RIGHTS OF LIFE
LIBERTY AND THE PURSUIT OF
HAPPINESS. I WOULD WISH TO
LEARN THE SPEECH BECAUSE WITH
BENEFITS BUT IS WHAT. ED IT WAS
THEN HELL YOUR JACKSON WHO IT
JUST BEFORE YOU TOOK THE STAGE
AND YOU SAYS TELL HIM ABOUT THE
DREAM MARTIN. TELL ME ABOUT THE
DREAM. ANY IMPROMPTU WENT TO IT
WOULD TO A SPEECH CITY HAD
GIVEN MANY TIMES ABOUT I HAVE A
DREAM. BUT I ASKED YOU TO LEARN
THE FIRST. MINUTES OF THAT
SPEECH AND UNDERSTAND THAT HE
SAYS. THE NEGRO IN NEW- IN THE
SOUTH CANNOT VOTE. IN A ****
YOUR DOES HE HAS NOTHING TO
VOTE FOR. BLACK KIDS SEEING
NEEDS OF WHITE ONLY A WHAT THAT
MEANT TO THEM SO LET'S
UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS ALL IN THAT
SPEECH I ALSO ASK THAT WHEN YOU
SING HAPPY BIRTHDAY MANY TIMES
THIS WEEK I CELEBRATED A
BIRTHDAY AND MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES CAME TO MY OFFICE
AND I APPRECIATE THAT. AND MANY
OFTEN SAY WE WANT TO SING A
REGULAR SONG WHAT A STEVIE
WONDER VERSION MANY DON'T KNOW
THAT WAS A SONG WRITTEN TO HELP
PASS A NATIONAL RECOGNITION OF
CELEBRATING DR KING'S BIRTHDAY
BY STEVIE WONDER. LISTEN TO THE
WORDS IT WAS A DEDICATION TO
STEVIE WONDER WROTE THAT SONG
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY TO PUT
PRESSURE ON THIS FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HE BROUGHT MILLIONS
OF IMAGES TO WASH DC FIGHTING
FOR. ME AFTER KINGS THEY ARE
NOW HOLIDAY WE FIRST MADE A
TEMP IN NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE
AND IF BILL FIVE G. SHORT
TIMERS MCCARTY WALK BESIDE BUT
THANK RONALD REAGAN. HE DID A
NINETY DAY PERIOD. OF CELEBRATE
ME THIRTY FOUR YEARS OF
CELEBRATING DR KING'S BIRTHDAY
AND WE ALL SHOULD BE HONORED
BUT AGAIN I SHE TO LEARN THE
SONG. WELL BECAUSE IT WAS NOT
IT SABAH. IT WAS ABOUT THE
CELEBRATION OF DR KING'S LIFE.
AND I WILL CLOSE WITH THESE
WORDS OF DR KING. THERE'S
NOTHING IN THIS WORLD. IN YEARS
SPENT SINCERE IGNORANCE AND
CONSCIENTIOUS STUPIDITY. I WILL
SAY THIS AGAIN THERE'S NOTHING
IN THIS WORLD MORE DANGEROUS
THAN SINCERE IN IGNORANCE AND
CONSCIENTIOUS STUPIDITY WE SELL
A LOT OF THAT GOING ON IN THIS
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
ON AS C. R. SIXTY SEVEN. THE
CENTER BRADFORD MATTER PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. ARCHULETA
ARE AYE ATKINS AYE BATES AYE
BELL. FIVE FOR JUST AYE
BRADFORD FIVE CABALLERO I
CHIANG. FIVE DOLLY FIVE DODD. I
ASSUME AYE GALGIANI. I GLAZER
FIVE GONZALEZ I WROTE.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO I
TADO I JACKSON AYE JONES. LEYVA
FIVE MCGUIRE I MITCHELL. MONEY
FIVE MORE LOT I MORRELL. FIVE
NIELSEN I PAN. HI PORTANTINO
FIVE ROTH FIVE RUBIO SKINNER.
HI STERN FIVE NUMBER I LIKE HOW
SKI I WIENER I WILL. HI. FIVE
THIRTY FOUR KNOWS ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. BRING ON
TO. OUR THAT'S THE FIN IT WILL
BE OUT FINISH THE CONSIDERATION
OF THE DAILY FILE WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO- MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS SENATOR WIENER YOU
HAVE EIGHTY ADJOURNED IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT ON. A
COLLEAGUES IT'S WITH GREAT
SADNESS- THAT I RISE TO JUST
TURN IN MEMORY OF A FORMER
COLLEAGUE OF MINE IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO CITY ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE- BUCK CALVINBALL. WHO
WAS A DEVOTED PUBLIC SERVANT TO
THE CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO- FOR
ALMOST A HALF A CENTURY AND A
BEACON OF INTEGRITY. ON
SATURDAY TOWARDS ME SEX AGE OF
SEVENTY SIX ARE SURROUNDED BY
HIS FAMILY HIS DEATH WAS WAS
NOT EXPECTED I WAS JUST A
TERRIBLE TRAGEDY IN SURPRISE
FOR EVERYONE. BUCK WAS BORN AND
ON THE RIVER TWELFTH NINETEEN
FORTY TWO IN OAKLAND WAS RAISED
IN PIEDMONT ATTENDED PIEDMONT
HIGH SCHOOL. GRADUATING FROM UC
DAVIS- HE EARNED HIS LAW DEGREE
FROM UC HASTINGS COLLEGE OF THE
LAW IN NINETEEN SIXTY NINE.
NINETEEN SEVENTY JOIN THE SAN
FRANCISCO CITY ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE- EMBARKING ON WHAT WOULD
BE A NEARLY FIFTY YEAR CAREER
AS A DEPUTY CITY ATTORNEY FOR
OUR GREAT CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
BALK WITH. THE CITY'S RESPONSE
TO THE ASSASSINATION OF MAYOR
MOSCONI AND SUPERVISOR HARVEY
MILK IN NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT-
HE WROTE THE OPINION ON HOW THE
SUPERVISORS SHOULD SELECT THE
NEXT MAYOR. HARVEY MILK WAS
DEAD DAN WHITE WAS IN JAIL AND
THAT SUPERVISOR DIANNE
FEINSTEIN COULDN'T BOOK FOR
HERSELF. BAKIT TURPITUDE. THE
CHARTER AND DECIDED THAT OF THE
EIGHT REMAINING SUPERVISORS IT
WOULD TAKE SIX VOTES NOT FIVE.
TO MAKE A MAJORITY- THAT WAS
ACTUALLY QUITE- AN IMPORTANT
DECISION BECAUSE IT HELPED
DETERMINE THE FUTURE OF THE
CITY FOR YEARS TO COME BOX
DEDICATED IN AN UNPARALLELED
LEGAL BRILLIANCE FOR SAN
FRANCISCO. AND THAT HIS ROLE
AS- WHAT WE WOULD CALL THE
ORACLE OF OUR CITY CHARTER- IF
BUCK EVER GAVE AN
INTERPRETATION THAT YOU DON'T
LIKE CAN YOU TRY TO GET SOMEONE
TO GIVE A DIFFERENT LOCATION.
THE FACT WAS THE BUCK WOULD
ALWAYS PREVAIL AND SOMETIMES
LEARN THIS TO MY DETRIMENT IF I
JUST. BECAUSE HE KNEW OUR CITY
CHARTER. TRADITIONS BETTER THAN
AT ONE- AND HE WAS TRULY
BRILLIANT- I HAD THE GREAT
PRIVILEGE OF WORKING WITH HIM
AND IT WAS AN HONOR TO CALL HIM
A FRIEND AND A NEIGHBOR HI HE
SURVIVES. HIS WERE GIVEN TO
EACH. OP PLEASE JOIN ME- INTO
DURING TODAY IN MEMORY ABOUT
THE ALLMAN FALL. THANK YOU
SENATOR WINNER PLEASE BRING THE
NAME- FORD AND MAKE SURE WE
PROPERLY ADJOURNED- NEXT UP FOR
JOURNEY MEMORIES SENATOR LABEL.
THANKS TO PRESIDENT GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS IS WITH GREAT
SADNESS THAT I ALSO WE ADJOURN
TODAY IN THE MEMORY OF ALAN
JOSEPH ACOSTA E. WHO DIED
SUDDENLY THIS PAST MONDAY. AT
THE EIGHT FORTY FIVE I'M SORRY.
WHAT'S VERGE MY CHIEF OF STAFF
CAMERON. I PRACTICED A LOT LAST
NIGHT DIDN'T HELP. IT IS
PASSING BECAUSE IT SHOCKED ALL
OF US AND CERTAINLY TO HIS
FAMILY AND HIS FRIENDS LOOKED
HIM SO DEEPLY. ELLEN PROP LIGHT
EVERYONE LIVES WITH. HIS KIND
AS HIS BRAVERY AND IF YOU KNEW
HIM YOU KNEW THAT HE KNEW HOW
TO TELL A GREAT STORY. EVERY
TIME I EVER SPOKE TO AT. GET
HIS WIT AND THE WAY HE MADE YOU
FEEL LIKE YOU'VE KNOWN YOU FOR
EVER AND HE ALWAYS MADE YOU
LAUGH AND SMILE. WITHOUT A
DOUBT ELLEN WAS ALWAYS READ
HAVE YOUR BACK IF YOU EVER
NEEDED HELP. WITH HIS BUT MOST
OF HIS LIFE HIS PROFESSIONAL
LIFE AS A BARTENDER SO WE KNOW
THAT MADE HIM A THERAPIST TOO
MANY. HAVING BEEN BORN AND
RAISED IN SACRAMENTO.
EVERYWHERE HE WENT HE RAN INTO
SOMEONE HE KNEW. ALLEN PLEASE
ALLOW PARK AND SO MANY PEOPLE
WHO WE CROSSED PATHS WITH BOTH
AT WORK. AND IN THE COMMUNITY
BUT ABOVE ALL THAT THAT ONE WAS
LOVED BY HIS WIFE AND HIS
FAMILY. AND SPENT THE LAST
CHAPTERS DEVOTED TO THEM AND
ALWAYS TEACHING HIM THAT WE
SHOULD LIVE TO THAT LIVING TO
AND BEING NICE IS NOT ENOUGH WE
SHOULD LIVE OUR LIVES WITH
KINDNESS. ALLEN IS DIVIDE BY
HIS WIFE CÃM. DAUGHTER
CAROLINA STEP CHILDREN JOSEPH
AND MY UP. FOR THOSE WHO ALLEN
CAMERON FOR MORE IT WILL BE
GOING IN THE NEXT X. INDEED TO
FOLLOW. I WOULD ALSO WE ALL
CONTINUE TO LIVE IN IS LEGACY
OF KINDNESS LOYALTY AND LOVE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN AND DURING
THE MEMORY OF ALLEN JOSEPH
KASKI THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER LABOR WILL EXTENDING OUR
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE TO
HIS FAMILY PLEASE MAKE SURE THE
NAMES BROUGHT FORTS OR CAN BE
PROPERLY MORE ALLIES-NICK TO
SENATOR SKINNER FOR YOUR
JOURNEY. THANK MEMBERS TO JOIN
ME IN A DURING IN MEMORY. FOR
ART SHANKS ARE CHINX WASA WELL
KNOWN CIVIL RIGHTS WORK FORCE
IN ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
ADVOCATE WHO FOUNDED OAKLAND'S
CYPRESS MANDELA TRAINING
PROGRAM THE CYPRESS MANDELA
TRAINING PROGRAM WAS THE V.
THREE FIRST. GREEN JOBS
CONSTRUCTION PROGRAM AND BROWN
FIELDS TRAINING PROGRAM EVER.
AND ART WAS A CONSTRUCTION
WORKER WHO WHEN THE LOMA PRIETA
EARTHQUAKE OCCURRED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE AND THOSE OF YOU
REMEMBER THAT FREEWAYS
STRUCTURE COLLAPSED IN OAKLAND
ART WAS DRIVING BY RIGHT BEFORE
THE COLLAPSE IN FELT THE
EARTHQUAKE AND THEN BECAUSE HE
LIVED IN THE AREA IMMEDIATELY
AS MOST OAKLAND WEST OAKLAND
RESIDENTS DID WENT TO THE
STRUCTURE TO TRY TO HELP RESCUE
PEOPLE. AFTER THE- YOU KNOW
ONCE ALL OF THE YEARS IT TOOK
PLACE BUT THERE WAS A PLAN TO
REBUILD WEST OAKLAND TO NATE TO
NOT PUT UP THAT FREEWAY AGAIN
BECAUSE IT'D DIVIDED THAT
COMMUNITY WAS A VERY LOW INCOME.
AND IN STE. ROAD WAS PUT
THROUGH CALLED PSYCH BLACK AND
ART WAS INSPIRED ALONG WITH HIS
BROTHER TO FOUND THIS TRAINING
CENTER TO PROVIDE THIS
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AND JOB
TRAINING TO THOSE RESIDENTS
FIRST WEST OAKLAND BUT BEYOND
THE NOW WITH THE HOLY SPACE.
WHO HAVE BEEN AFFECT FAILED BY
OUR EDUCATION SIT. OR WERE
JUSTICE SYSTEM IMPACT. OR THE
LIKE SO THE PEOPLE THAT THE
CYPRESS MENDOZA TRAINING
PROGRAM TRAINED WHERE PEOPLE
WITHOUT HIGH SCHOOL DEGREES
PEOPLE WITH RECORDS PEOPLE THAT
OTHERWISE WE'RE NOT REALLY
GOING TO GET A DECENT JOB. WHEN
THEY JOINED UP WITH THE MENTAL
TRAINING CENTER THEY COMMIT TO
A YEAR. AND FOR THE FIRST MONTH
THEY WERE NOT PAID AN ART.
COULD UPON THAT BECAUSE HE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
WERE WILLING TO MAKE THE
COMMITMENT TO REALLY GET THE
TRAINING WHICH INCLUDED. FIVE
WERE A LIFE SKILLS IT WASN'T
ONLY THE WORK FORCE SKILLS THAT
TRAINING CENTER PARTNERED WITH
AC TRANSIT WITH PARK WITH P.
JEANNIE AND GRADUATES WENT ON
IT WAS A PRE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM. AND THOSE PARTNERSHIPS
AT TWO HUNDRED THOSE GRADUATES
GOING INTO STATE CERTIFIED
PRESSURE PROGRAMS AND THEN
GETTING BOB'S AT PLACES LIKE P.
JEANNIE AND LOOK AT THE BET
YOU'LL SEE MANY P. JEANNIE
WORKERS. KLAY SCRIBE THEY HAVE
A JOB TO. WORK DUE TO THERE
BEING THE CYPRESS MANDELA
TRAINING PROGRAM IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN ART RECEIVED
THE OUR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AWARD FROM ACT FOR EXCELLENCE
FROM THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES IN THOUSAND AND
FIVE P. RIZZI RISK EXEMPLARY
PUBLIC INTEREST CONTRIBUTION BY
THE US DEPARTMENT OF LABOR HE
RECEIVED MANY MANY TECHNICIANS
NATIONALLY AND LOCALLY-
INCLUDING THE JEFFERSON AWARD
IN RECOGNITION PORTING
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT IN
OAKLAND. I DON'T EFFECTIVELY HE
PASSED AWAY FOR TWENTY NINE THE
YOUNG AGE OF SIX FOR ALL WEST
WIND THE E. BAY ARTS BILLION
FRIENDS WILL DEARLY MISS HIS
VISIONARY LEADERSHIP. WE HAVE
THIS CALIFORNIA SENATE WE
EXTEND OUR DEEPEST CONDOLENCES
AND PLEASE BRING THE NAME PORTS
OR COULD BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. MEMBERSHIP
THERE'S NO BUSINESS CENTER
ACTIONS THE JUSTICE CLERK.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND-
COLLEAGUES I HOPE YOU HAVE AN
INCREDIBLY WONDERFUL WEEKEND
BACK HOME IN YOUR DISTRICTS
HOPEFULLY ENJOYING MANY
TRIBUTES TO THE HONORABLE-
MARTIN LUTHER KING- I KNOW WE
ALL HAVE EVENTS THAT WE WILL BE
DOING. AND I HOPE YOU HAVE A
GREAT WEEKEND- DOING THAT AND
PULLS WALL WE WILL YOU CAN IN
ON TUESDAY TUESDAY. JAN TWENTY
FIRST. TWO P. THANK YOU MISTER.
THURMOND PROTIUM THE SENATE
WILL BE RECESSED UNTIL THREE
THIRTY WHICH TIME HONORED
GERMAN. MOTION WILL BE MADE
WILL COMPLETE RECONVENE THE
SENATE ON TUESDAY AT TWO PM WE
STAND IN RECESS